[Music]
so i
i talked to i talked behind closed doors
with people for
a long time years and years and years
and
someone in your situation whose mom
essentially rescued him as a young kid
you have brothers and sisters i have one
brother okay got
people out and then she
passes away that can be an untethering
moment for people
what kept that from being an untethering
moment for you well depends what you
mean by untethering right
so uh when i think of tethers i think of
that as a metaphor for
keeping me bound to something and not
being free ah so
it was a freedom moment yeah in a way
not not because of her but
because of what happened i think one of
two things could have happened whenever
there's a sort of
car crash like that you can either
course correct
or you can use that car crash to careen
into something else
right and then it turns into this this
terrible accident
um so when my mom died i went down to
florida she had when she
she moved down there right before she
passed like a few months before she
found out she had stage four lung cancer
she had moved down there to finally
retire
right and so she spent her last days in
in st
petersburg florida living off social
security and
and i went down there one last time
after she passed and
this time was to deal with her stuff and
she had she wasn't a hoarder but she had
65 years worth of accumulations right
she had stuff and it was all crammed
into this one-bedroom apartment
old antique furniture and it wasn't junk
it was things she had accumulated she
really found value in
but the things that are sentimental to
her i could
add sentiment to them and make them
sentimental to me
but i realized in that moment before the
whole minimalism thing it was in fact it
was my first sort of
uh dipping my toe into the waters of
minimalism
i had to deal with her stuff so i looked
all these things and i did what any good
son would do i rented a giant u-haul
in fact i had to wait an extra day to
get that 26-foot u-haul right
i was just going to bring it all back to
ohio now i already had my own house with
a full basement full of stuff an attic
full of stuff bedrooms full of stuff
so i couldn't co-mingle mom's stuff with
my stuff and so i
rented a big storage locker to just keep
all of her things like a mausoleum of
stuff
yes that's a great way to phrase that
and
and then i was looking through these
things and i i had a few sort of
realizations as i was going through the
things the first one was that
i was holding on to it because i was
holding on to her memories and i saw
i found these four boxes under her bed
it was my old elementary school
paperwork grades one through four and i
realized oh
she was holding on to the memories of me
then i also realized like wait these
boxes have moved from house to house to
house and they've been sealed for
decades no one's ever opened them yes
never and so the memories aren't in our
things
the memories are inside us and that was
like the first big aha moment as i was
going through those things
and then i looked around all over all of
her things and i said oh wait a minute
i'm getting ready to do the same thing
except instead of storing her things in
a box under my bed
i was going to cram it all into this big
box with a padlock on it
a storage locker and then pay hundreds
of dollars every month to keep things
what just in case the three most
dangerous words
in the english language those three
words justify
us holding on to so many things that are
actually getting in the way
of our contentment and so
i called up u-haul and i cancelled the
truck and then i um
i called and i canceled the storage
locker i spent the next 12 days
selling or donating almost everything
not everything but almost everything
and and i learned some other lessons
along the way one was about sentimental
items
because if i would have kept thousands
of sentimental items well
that's sort of like watering down the
sentiment in a way but by keeping just a
handful of sentimental items
i was able to get far more value from
those few things i kept
than if they were all just crammed into
that giant storage lock
i was so happy when i got that phone
call because i was supposed to go down
there and help him move all that stuff
that's the worst thing about having
friends
is the move there's nothing worse i'd
rather my friend call and say hey man
um my house is on fire i'll help you but
it's
hey man uh can you help me move nope i
had somebody asked me one time i was
like i will pay for half of
the moving company to move your stuff
actually two buddies that's how i will
help you
they they were gonna show up to my house
on a saturday morning to move and a
truck rolled up and they said i bought
an hour and he bought an hour
we're not lifting we're not doing that
but yeah so tell me about your growing
up
oh man um yeah so i
yeah i had a lot of uh drug abuse uh
physical abuse um
my mom and dad split up when i was in
the second grade
uh my dad was a very strict very
hardcore jehovah's witness
so i grew up kind of in that religion i
lived with him most of my childhood
um my mom uh he got married had a kid my
mom got married had four kids
so i've got five half brothers and
sisters
um yeah i mean yeah step dad was
uh yeah he yeah he used to be the crap
out of me for sure
um but you know it's at 40 years old
oh man i've been through so much therapy
and you know different work like
letting go of the trauma and stuff and
uh i feel i feel like i have been able
to let go
of a lot of that um even with my mom
like my dad doesn't talk to me right now
because i'm not a jehovah's witness and
i've kind of like
yes spoken out against like hey man
which i thought i was going to be like
oh dad here's why you shouldn't be a
jehovah's witness and he was like i'm
not talking to you anymore
i'm like oh i should probably shouldn't
have done that um
and then uh my my mom her and i are
actually
really doing a good job of like
rekindling our relationship
and uh you know forgiving each other for
because i guess we both probably put
each other through some trauma like
as a child i used to think like oh i'm
not responsible
for putting her through trauma and maybe
i'm not but
her the stuff that comes up is still
those are her battles so like i got to
respect the stuff that comes up for her
so
she's actually coming out to a visit um
like in a week or so
with my little niece um yeah so my
brothers and sisters i have one sister
uh from my dad like i said half sister
she's
doing awesome she like started her own
like social media company she's doing
great
then i've got like i've got a brother in
prison right now
um i got another brother and kind of he
hasn't been to jail in a while
but he's you know kind of he was in and
out i got a sister in like a
in rehab right now um and then i have
another sister who she's doing pretty
good she's got a couple kids like found
a good guy
uh so there's just a lot on my mom's
side there's a lot of
i don't know angst i don't know what to
call it you know just drama yeah just
drama that's going on yeah
swat team kicked in his door in the
eighth grade yeah yeah true story
true story yeah um that's sort of like
that's the
that that's the opening scene to some to
like the movie about
your childhood trauma it feels like is
the swat team kicking in your
front door yeah oh yeah so one of the
misconceptions i think of folks who
look and say if i could and i think
that's that
that pursuit of happiness that phrase if
i could just i think that's a
damaging sentence if i could just fill
in the blank once you get past
have a place to sleep it's a food yeah
some relationships basically
if i could just is man
if i was able to write a book get an
audience get a thing get a thing then
slate gets wiped clean for me
everything's easy
beautiful spouses show up and just want
to marry you right
what i love i mean i appreciate your
vulnerability and honesty here is
there's human stories behind all this
stuff and those human stories show up
in random places at weird times and
still got two moms coming in a week yeah
exhale right and here we're gonna i'm
gonna be intentional about
how right and that backs me i before
this conversation
i had wrapped my head around minimalism
as a
way of being with stuff it's not it's a
it has to do with
an approach to how you walk through life
yeah right
because some of the things you're saying
about getting rid of i hear that when
people call the show when they're
talking about
a toxic spouse or a toxic store you've
been telling yourself your whole life or
parents who
fill in the blank have their own version
of the way you should be living or
whatever that looks like
and the ethos sounds like it works
they're the same right it's just an
approach to earth
yeah i mean stuff is it's the initial
bite of the apple
like all that physical stuff is just
it's a physical manifestation of what's
going on in here so once you get rid of
that at least for me when i got rid of
that
outward stuff and i know it's worked for
millions of other people but
you start to make room to work with that
spiritual clutter the mental clutter all
that internal stuff that's going on you
can start to examine
not just like why am i bringing you know
why am i bringing this book into my life
it's you know why am i bringing this
relationship into my life why am i
bringing this job into my life
again yeah and again right right right
right right right yeah why am i bringing
in this pursuit into my life
so um yeah it's it's it is uh it's
interesting how minimalism
uh yeah it's it's kind of the the stuff
is kind of the trojan horse
yeah that's where it starts but it does
go so much deeper so what makes are
y'all parents
yeah you have kids yeah i've got an
eight-year-old eight-year-old okay
so what are you doing different what
makes you what makes you a good dad
well i think i think kids are so much
wiser than their parents
and i don't mean like earned knowledge
over the years and
that's something that's different but
it's funny i her school
teaches her mindfulness which is
hilarious because who's more mindful
than a child
and what that really tells me is that
school spends 6 hours and 45 minutes a
day
making her not mindful and then they
they try to say well now we're going to
get back into our
minds so to speak but who is more
intentional who's more in the moment who
is more
present than a child and so i think
as a parent i have so much to learn from
my daughter like how to be human in a
way because
i've unlearned that humanity over the
last
40 years or whatever and it's been
acculturated
out of me right especially through the
pursuit of the things you know the thing
you want is never the thing you want
yeah you think you want i had a lexus
and that didn't do it for me so i bought
a second lexus
so now i have lexi and two car payments
and you know whatever it is a 72 month
loan and all of these
these things and it's like oh but what
did i actually want there oh i wanted
status i wanted significance hmm
that's fascinating you think you're
going to get significance from a shiny
car i'm a depreciating asset yeah right
how weird is that right well
why do i think that well because i've
been told that i've seen other people
who i believe to be significant
and that's not to say there's anything
wrong with the car i own a car now right
there's not even anything wrong with
alexis i'm sure they make
wonderful cars the problem is thinking
that is the
the thing to do it's going to solve me
yeah and so the thing i've learned from
ella is my daughter is is that
we're so far away from the moment all
the time we're clinging to the past
right where we're clinging to some
hypothetical
non-existent future right and
we're so far away from right here
right now one of the things i recommend
to parents all the time is to touch your
kid's face
and there's a lot of um
physiology about kids and nerve endings
in their face
but what often that's a trick for me to
get parents to put their phones down
and get eye level with their kid and
be present with their kid right it's a
it's a
it's a both hand right but there's
something about that presence right yeah
um can i start touching your face josh
that's what this show's for and uh you
didn't know this was coming josh
so you know he's gonna be your guy i'll
start doing that with my wife i'll just
start touching it yeah
i love it what's one thing your kids
gonna learn from you
yeah i well my friend rob bell says that
that
that kids are always learning from you
and sometimes it's from your words
they watch you that's right yeah and so
it's fascinating i remember when she was
really young and i would you know
tell her it's like make sure you use
your fork and then all of a sudden three
seconds later she
sees me pull a piece of broccoli off her
mom's plate and pop it on
and of course it's like oh i'm telling
you to do one thing and it's i've become
a parody of the parent where it's like
do as i say not as i do right and so
i think what she'll learn from me is
well it's the title of the book really i
mean it's love people use things right
for the longest time i've
used people and loved things and we have
a language problem
you know i can say that i love you john
but i also
love tacos right and
we one thing means like extreme like i
think most of us we don't really
understand love
not even a little bit no to love someone
is to see
them who they are without trying to
change them
right and and so if ella learns anything
from me it's that she's her own human
being she's not me
it's not me trying to force her into
anything although any
any time i do because i feel like i
always know what is best
sometimes i do boundaries are important
for an eight-year-old
of course sometimes we can erect these
unnecessary boundaries
you ever been to someone's house and
they just have too many walls in it yes
you're like well wait a minute what who
decided to put a wall here and then one
right there as well
i think we do that so frequently with
our kids and with our relationships in
general we're putting up all of these
barriers between us
for this imaginary catastrophic ending
that more than likely won't ever
come that's right yeah and if it does
those walls aren't going to stop it
anyway right so yeah